[Music]
and no privacy news my worst nightmares
a bit abaya the boy right hahaha a court
filing says FBI paid geek squad
informants to search computers for child
porn that's kind of smart Geek Squad
that is from Best Buy but not yeah Wow
is that legal
that's the issue Rajon a privacy broke
yeah FBI can't do that I think it's okay
I think it's right it's cool that you're
doing that for that purpose but is also
not okay because that's that's a [ __ ]
when you call a [ __ ] so like if you give
them this type of access it'll lead it
to something else
yes what if Geek Squad becomes a new
like CIA it's like a government agency
but they keep the name key people I
it'll snow snowball effect you like this
that is like searching without a warrant
yeah exactly I would just call and what
if they're just saying it's pretty yeah
and if you're getting everything other
stuff yeah I don't like this year in
recent court documents the documents
reveal how at least four technicians who
work for a Best Buy's Geek Squad had
received hundreds of dollars from the
FBI to search for child porn on
customers computers what do you even get
child porn is that even legal to bribe
people yeah and out of the pain these
individual employees are is it like the
Geek Squad companies everything is okay
in the name of finding child porn so
this case is more closely directed
towards a particular Geek Squad located
out in Kentucky because that of branch
out there they're the ones that do hard
drives recoveries like so yeah your hard
drive crashes and you take it to Best
Buy's by far as like okay we need to
ship it over to this branch so that they
can recover all the data that you lost
and so that's okay by doing so when you
recover the data sometimes you know most
likely to recover the data that's like
you know if you even thrown away from a
long time ago right and so this has been
in the news because there's a case
against a California doctor who was
charged with possession of child porn on
his computer because he dropped off his
computer with the geek squad and then
they shipped it over and then they found
that there's a picture of a young girl
right just one picture to my knowledge
is one picture
maybe that could be accidental tourism
how do you accidentally get a young
girls titty in your picture doesn't know
I got a computer I've like cookies or
something I don't know just in case like
in this case of the California he's just
saying that like oh well this evidence
isn't it's not like and you can use it
yeah so you just seem they're like oh
I'm this evidence like can't even be
used because I've deleted this like a
long time ago and like the fact that
like you guys like all of a sudden like
when you restored everything like it's
already there it's just like this is my
private stuff like how could you go
through like how did you go through my
stuff because I only asked you to
recover my data right but the thing is
that for peak squad if they ever do come
across child pornography they do have to
report it
so in this doctors case what he's trying
to fight for is that the FBI is paying
geek squad to actively like look out for
child porn or like dig through and like
search algorithm visit doctor have like
a lot of is just one picture to my
knowledge from what Geek Squad found it
was one to join it was a deleted picture
from a long time ago because his hard
drive person he wanted to restore data
and so amongst the visitors yeah if he
doesn't have like a terabyte of child
porn and all this stuff because then
it's hard to kind of argue like how does
he know that this is just Geek Squad
policy if they just come across any
childhood in the I might we have to
report it how does he know that it's the
FBI
he keeps fun apparently there were
documents that did have records of the
FBI paying geek squad for this out there
for like I guess how was the doctor know
that so in terms of that like I don't
know how she was able to dig up that
information but like his lawyer was able
to bring that into court saying like hey
here's some evidence at the FBI
they paid geek squad like this X amount
of money well maybe they had evidence
against and then that's it was a painter
illegal means you can't do that I
hopefully he's not a [ __ ] rapist I'm
not kind of protective like pedophile or
whatever whatnot [ __ ] yeah it's hard to
judge one picture do you know what I
want to figure out if I was gay or not
and I just looked up gay pornos and I
what they do something like random
cookie of like two dudes [ __ ] on my
computer yeah it's like that's [ __ ] up
like I don't even all I got there well I
do not because I went on a website maybe
a download it
how but let's say there's a person out
there that's like hey I don't know if
I'm a pedophile and I want to test this
little pedophile and there's that one
picture and he finds out he's not a
pedophile but then now he has that
random cookie that's embedded and now
he's labeled a pedophile and he isn't
even a pedophile I just wanted to test
it out or you got hacked and somebody
went into your computer and put in all
these can't get all this [ __ ] on can I
just send it to you without you yeah
only you just open it yeah what the [ __ ]
is this that's true yeah cuz people send
dirty jokes all the time and then how
about you fool Oh that'll be [ __ ] up
so you hack somebody's computer plant
all this crazy [ __ ] inside there and
then you call the cops and saying I
think this guy is producing child porn
and you've got drug-dealing going on and
all the stuff you need to go right now
and he's armed and dangerous and the
SWAT team comes over Bowl and they check
that computer you got hot rehan it wow
wow what you gonna do thou no so I feel
like this case with the California
what's going on oh so I feel like this
case with the California doctor is just
tough just because they did a search on
his phone and there were hundreds of
images of young girls okay people Jared
Fogle in his ass in jail but but we are
seen they can't use that in law in the
court of law just because it was
obtained illegally
yeah if is that new photo on his
computer was obtained illegally then
whatever they found on his phone is
thrown oh oh not maybe his wife will
know and she'll find some [ __ ] it's okay
his reputation is ruined
down Ewan
like underage girls not 18 19 20
year-olds no cuz if there were 20
year-olds life is an issue they're just
poor he just likes porn well from from
what I read is photos of young girls and
it also includes photos that were taken
during a gynecological exam
gynecological gynecology yeah so he's a
cheater do and how the [ __ ] my doctor
had never taken shots or do you have a
guy yeah the guy no yes I guess you
couldn't really see like let's say he
has a new lab coat and you have like you
know your it's draped over under and
there's another girl isn't there - yeah
no I guess I'm saying like for what like
how this guy got away with you taking
selfies with a [ __ ] like that's so
crazy you [ __ ] scumbag three slides
it up what's it look like can we see a
picture again yeah let's accept glasses
they only look like that all with da
glasses why he did why does he look like
he took this picture at the mall in 1990
any sort of Kaiser I think that's the
kind of memory the always tell my god
dr. McClure Bert
thanks pervert Mick some frog I don't
know you look so innocent mark a red
Meyer ladies if you're kind of conscious
that dude just till he [ __ ] I'm not
checking her vagina he was fingering
your [ __ ] oh my god I personally hope
he doesn't win because it's really
because when when you give your computer
to Geek Squad you give them the consent
for them to like go through your
computer also he did send up a more yeah
I mean yeah but then like what he's
trying to apply for is that oh no this
is a regal because the FBI got involved
with it I hope that they could surpass
this so they could put his ass in jail
how can his lawyer defend this guy
exactly
there's no I wonder if I kill so even be
able to practice he won't be for sure
I'm pretty sure it's like his room dr.
disco but he won't go to jail I'd like
to be really you [ __ ] help so maybe
he's just going to arrest her for the
Huntington Beach because of this four
out of potentially eight Geek Squad
workers were exposed
three of them were fired one of them was
for what for being [ __ ] heroes for
being informant so like FBI would tell
them like hey I need you to like both
my computer also BestBuy they're like we
don't have no rat yeah so [ __ ]
I don't know best bottom off you then I
guess there you look at company policy
and all that [ __ ] ethics exactly and
like best bites is like oh we we never
got hired by the FBI like we don't we
don't tolerate yeah like we don't
tolerate any of this because it is an
invasion of privacy what do you do
another one that comes with the [ __ ]
wallet wow you're just like oh yeah you
think that you're gonna be safe because
they're the law yeah I would have felt
like Geek Squad undercover joke so cool
where do I sign up
yeah I signed up for that [ __ ] anybody I
joined Geek Squad they want to be a part
of something very much a squad if you
work for Best Buy no I'm Geek Squad it
yeah Department I'm a special agent for
geeks yeah like what the [ __ ] don't ever
[ __ ] put me up with those sales rent
geeks yeah what am I gonna give me a
[ __ ] done fixed is hard drive blah
blah blah
yeah like Best Buy guys are like the
police that patrol the streets Geek
Squad 30 detectives we see if they're
the [ __ ] true crime they're like the
guys that Panthers yep from what I know
four of them accepted the money from the
FBI's well which what one unlock or try
to return the money back oh all I got to
do is tell toe and I make money and
saving the world from rapist so are
those before people are not fired what
have you no no no so three out of the
four they were fired and then I'm
assuming the one that tried to get the
money back was we was the one that was
real oh don't give that money back we
look another for the other four I yeah
II clogged you did an honorable thing
don't feel ashamed you cop some perverts
and guess what you got paid for helping
the Sabbagh you fought crime
good job don't let nobody tell you
otherwise hello mana people do you want
to contact me and everybody else you see
go ahead and check the description box
below and follow our social medias is
the Grahams and Twitter's
for more videos click up there baby
[Music]